[Musique]
les émissions avec jon maia et céline
vous allez bien oui super mais toi très
bientôt en forme on va faire un petit
jeu ensemble on va essayer de tester
votre couple aurait d'abord te poser les
questions puis à toi des questions si
vous avez un maximum de bonnes réponses
à vous remportez ce fabuleux cadeau
c'est des massages et d'espacé libyenne
est gmail à tulle à partir on va te
mettre dans un coin pour ne pas que tu
entends des réponses vagues s'inquiète
pas c'est l'hymne à l'amour entre homos
c'est quoi confiance sécurité et puis
joie quelle est la plus belle preuve
d'amour que des fêtes des mayas je pense
être sincères est correctement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh pardon excusez moi
[Musique]
reste avec moi et m'a neeson on va bien
tu cherches rip n'est évidemment
n'entend pas les bonnes réponses
d'accord a tout de suite alors théo
quelle est la musique préférée de
madison grn be your lover tissage je
sais qu'elle écoute moi des échos
bâtonnets est ce que tu fais ce que tu
fais trop
et encore ils étaient des vrais gens je
pense qu'il y avait la télé ce genre en
procès où j'ai eu peur
j'aurais pu tous alors on va commencer
par un toit à l'occ si tu restes avec
moi horvath se tenait un petit peu pour
l'instant les réponses à la torche
quelle est la plus belle preuve d'amour
comptez fait alexis bac elle me dit oui
à ma demande tu a tendu la main on
précise j'ai fait le jour de mon
anniversaire le 6 octobre
d'accord pas d'accord alors
excusez moi messieurs dames il me semble
que la gamme de la connaît alors on va
commencer par toi si tu restes avec moi
et ils s on va venir te récupérer pour
être un peu plus loin comme ça j'ai
entendre a passé toute la course
c'est quoi la chose la plus folle que tu
es fait par amour avec une herse alors
vous n'avez restaurant aux questions
mohamed c'est que toi
la définition selon toi de la femme
parfaite à foca prennent soin d'elle
c'est pas ta meuf
[Musique]
et oui mais si ça avait été une offre
sur la régie
bayard mais le rouge suis pas ma femme
toit a témoigné un petit peu pour pas
que tu entends tu les réponses de notre
ami qu'il y en a sur hors jeu le gardeur
t'inquiète pas idiot tu le fais quoi
comme cadeau pour la saint valentin
je lui ai acheté qu'est ce que je vais
acheter je vais acheter une petite
peluche
ouais c'est une peluche mais elle est
trop lourde c'est pas ta meuf là je vous
la gueule une personne c'est ça
[Musique]
marguerite
qu'est ce qui se passe ce qui vient donc
j'aime bien mais c'est surtout le
monsieur il est grand il se perd donc
jamais explosé
du coup on a gagné le stock
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]